bueno como pueden ver estoy en mi
oficina aquí en el capitolio he estado
aquí desde esta mañana espero quedarme
aquí hasta que terminemos nuestro
trabajo hoy o regresar a mi casa y
volver mañana pero creo definitivamente
que antes de salir de washington a
nuestro respectivo distrito deberemos de
terminar el trabajo que recomienda la
constitución de los estados
hay alguna orden oficial todavía reina
la incertidumbre no saben cómo
continuará no sabe como decía bien usted
no sabe si continuarán debatiendo luego
del toque de queda quizás
pero la la fbi fue convocada aquí
también la guardia nacional y de otros
equipos de seguridad han acudido aquí a
al capitolio y nosotros estamos
esperando de que yo no den más informe
en torno a la situación para ver si es
posible que esta noche o mañana podamos
retornar a nuestra jornada de trabajo y
concluir con el trabajo que no
encomienda de nuevo la la constitución y
le hice ya esta pregunta a un colega
suyo pero me gustaría realizarse la
también a usted no para conocer sobre
todo para la audiencia internacional y
quienes estamos tan lejanos conocer y
preguntarle cómo vivieron esos primeros
minutos esos primeros momentos en los
que los manifestantes a favor de donald
trump ingresaron llegaron al capitolio
luego ingresaron cuéntenos cómo como lo
vivieron ustedes desde adentro como
congresistas
bueno yo estaba en mi oficina no había
llegado al piso del capitolio pero
naturalmente nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a ver protestas incluso
protestas más grandes que ésta pero no a
ver la incidencia de violencia de
vandalismo del altercado que que se
presentó yo diría es citado por el mismo
presidentes y sus allegados porque hace
semanas de que el presidente le está
incitando a este sector que es un sector
desde que creo en mi opinión muy
personal es es un sector minoritario
pero violento no es descriptivo del
pueblo americano yo creo que el pueblo
americano está esta noche viendo todo
esto sorprendido y hasta cierto modo se
siente incómodo si todo lo que está
sucediendo en esta nación
adriano tienen alguna información
oficial digamos cómo va a continuar
ahora todo nada todo es incertidumbre
está mostrando que las agencias de
olores no deben un informe de comentar
la situación para ver cuándo y cómo
podemos proceder con nuestras con
nuestros trabajos usted conoce bien el
funcionamiento seguramente de las
fuerzas de seguridad del capitolio y
muchísimos analistas le han manifestado
por lo menos que les llama la atención
cómo han podido ingresar los
manifestantes pero donald trump le llamó
la atención esto por mucho tiempo ya yo
he pensado de que el nivel de seguridad
del capitolio estaba muy muy muy flojo
muy muy débil y que realmente estamos
sujetos a cualquier tipo de incidente
como este si es desafortunado que
sucediera ahora cuando estábamos
precisamente en un proceso tan
importante como es el conteo de los
votos de los delegados del colegio
electoral que define y naturalmente
quién es el próximo presidente o sea
estamos ratificando los resultados que
ya todos conocemos pero sí yo creo que
amerita una reflexión ahora y ver qué
medidas necesarias se deben de tomar
para que tanto nosotros como el público
en general sean protegidos aquí en el
capitolio de los auxilios y amerita
también crea usted una reflexión de cara
a la sociedad no fragmentada que van a
tener que gobernar durante el próximo
mandato de joe biden
pero yo creo que como dije anteriormente
no creo que es así yo creo que esto es
una puñada de personas que que cualquier
sector cuenta con un grupo de personas
de este índole extremistas que se
manifestaron aquí hoy pero que no
representan realmente ni el corazón ni
el sentir del pueblo norteamericano el
pueblo norteamericano puede tener
diferencias de opiniones pero es
respetuoso es un pueblo que trata de
regirse dentro de los parámetros de la
ley no violenta la ley sin duda hoy se
violentó la ley es posible que el mismo
presidente estuvo involucrado en algún
algún incidente de ilegal eso se tendría
que investigar de por que pase todo esto
pero yo tengo fe de que el pueblo
americano se va a unir y que realmente
no es el el sector que estaba presente
ahí al capitolio estatal de manera que
ahora usted para el mandato de joe biden
una gobernabilidad estable
yo veo yo creo que sí que por tal razón
el pueblo norteamericano le ha entregado
control tanto de la cámara representante
como hicieron anoche también en el
estado de georgia del senado y de la
rama ejecutiva al partido que yo
pertenezco que es el partido demócrata y
esperan de que se pueda restaurar aquí
la confianza en el gobierno la serenidad
y tranquilidad para el pueblo
norteamericano
señores peleas muchísimas gracias por
estos minutos con france24 ha sido
realmente muy importante escuchar su voz
desde el propio congreso de eeuu